Transcriber: Bashar Al-Thawabta
المدقّق: SHIMA BAGHERZADEH
كيف كنا قبل خمسمائة عام من الآن ؟
وأين سنكون بعد خمسين عاماً؟
عقولنا التي غرسنا فيها التفكير الخطي،
ولسبب واضح جداً.
الإنسان الأول قبل ملايين السنين كان
يركض خلف فريسته ويستخدم أدوات،
كنا مبتكرين في أن نتسارع على فريستنا،
كنا نستخدم الرماح حتى ننقض على فريستنا.
لكن مع مجتمع مع عالم متغير
بشكل متسارع جداً،
هل التفكير الخطي هو سلاحنا في هذه المرحلة؟
هل التفكير الخطي هو الذي سيُعيننا على كل
هذه الثورات التقنية؟
الإنسان الأول قبل ملايين السنين كانت
أهم مهارة في السيرة الذاتية له،
المهارة الأكثر طلبا هي مهارة الجهد العالي.
في قطر، قريب من هنا، وجدوا جمجمة
تعود إلى تسعين ألف سنة قبل الميلاد،
وجدوا فيها أن الانسان
بنيته الجسمانية تزيد بمعدل
عشرين بالمئة عن أجسامنا اليوم،
لكن عقله يبلغ النصف.
والسبب ثورة أحدثناها نحن،
شيء كنا نراه في البراكين،
كنا نراه في الطبيعة، في البرق عندما يضرب
في الأشجار
ولكن لم نكن نقدر أن نتحكم فيه،
ما كنا نقدر نشعله،
نطفئه، نوجهه،
إلى أن وجدنا الحل،
حجر وعصا.
وأول شرارة في تاريخ البشرية.
هذه الشرارة أعطتنا النار، المنتج
الذي أعطانا أربع ثورات صناعية.
كل ما نراه إحدى بنات النار، الإضاءة،
الكهرباء، كلها من بعض بنات النار.
هذه النار لم تكتف أن تغير كل ما حولنا من
محيط
بل تعدى ذلك ووصل إلى تغيير مباشر في
عقولنا،
النار أعطتنا إحدى التقنيات الرئيسية
ألا وهي تقنية الطبخ.
الطبخ أعطانا التغذية المثالية
التي أعطت عقولنا من وزن ستمئة
غرام في السابق إلى
وزن ألف وثلاثمائة وخمسين، أي الضعف.
لكن هذه المهارة، الجهد المضاعف،
كان في السابق
بسبب هذه المهارة، بسبب مهارة الطبخ
وقدرتنا على التغذية
تشكلت لنا أكثر من تريليون وصلة عصبية،
أعطتنا عقول أكثر ذكاء، والذي هو اليوم
المهارة الأكثر طلباً، هي مهارة الذكاء،
سرعة الاستنتاج ، الاستنباط ، التحليل .
لكن كل هذه الأشياء تتطلب شيئاً أخر أيضاً،
شيء لم نكن نتحكم به والتي هي المعرفة .
كانت المعرفة متاحة لكن ليس
بنفس السهولة اليوم.
كانت تأتينا بالكتب، المذياع، أياً كانت
الوسيلة،لكن لم تكن متاحة بنفس ما هي اليوم.
جهاز صغير بحجم الجيب كان بحجم منزل في
السابق، وليس من زمن طويل
بل أقل من مئة عام، وصل إلى حجم الجيب.
هذا الجهاز غيرنا من الخارج وأوصلنا
إلى ناس عالميين،
من كنا ناس محليين،
بعد الصلاة بين البيت والمسجد.
وقت الصلاة بالساعات.
صلاة العصر.
أحاديث، كنا ناساً محليين،
إلى أن أحدث هذا ثورة.
كنا نلعب في الحارة،
العصر مباراة.
صرنا اليوم نلعب مع شخص من أقصى
الأرض بسبب هذه التقنية.
غيرتنا ولم تغير شكل تواصلنا، غيرت
حتى مفاهيمنا في الحياة .
مفهوم العلاقات اختلف ، مفهوم أنك تحترمني
وأحترمك اختلف، كان في الماضي
إذا مررت لم تسلم علي،أو لم تشر بيدك هكذا،
لكن اليوم تغير ذلك حتى مفهوم الحب تغير.
هذا الجهاز الذي صنعناه انتهى إلى
إعادة تشكيلنا،
إعادة صناعتنا بطريقة أو بأخرى.
هذا الجهاز الذي كان بحجم المنزل،
أصبح بحجم الهاتف بحجم الجيب،
وسيصبح عما قريب بحجم
خلية الدم
التي بالإمكان أن تدخل في أجسامنا
وتغير حتى من بصمتنا الوراثية.
ثلاث تقنيات رئيسية العالم
ينتظرها: تقنية
علم الوراثة، النانو تكنولوجي
وتقنية الروبوتات.
دمج هذه التقنيات الثلاث بنفس ما دمجنا
الأمر في الهاتف
من اتصالات وإنترنت وإم بي ثري MP3
توصلنا إلى الهاتف.
بنفس التقنية سوف ندمج ثلاث تقنيات.
هذه سوف تغير الشفرة الوراثية لنا.
سوف تكون منتج ثورياً.
الشفرة الوراثية، لاقدر الله، من
الممكن وجود شفرة وراثية
معدل إصابتها بمرض السكري عالي،
هذه الأجهزة تدخل إلى جسم الإنسان
وتعيد ترتيب هذه البصمة الوراثية.
حيث أن الإنسان بالإمكان يمحي كل
ما يتعلق بمسببات هذا المرض.
يقال أن جسم الإنسان يمكن أن يصل أو عمر
الإنسان يمكن أن يصل إلى
أكثر من مائة وخمسين عام.
وفي رواية أخرى الذي لا يملك حس فكاهي
يمكن ان يضاف له سكر يُقال (نكتة).
لكن هذه التقنيات كلها،
دمج هذه التقنيات الثلاث سيوصلنا إلى
معرفة وجودية
ألا وهي التكيف.
وعندما أقول التكيف لا يعنى التنازل
والتراجع والرفض، وأن نرضى بأي شيء يكون
في الطاولة،
بل العكس إننا نتقدم ونرتقي بهذه التقنيات.
بالإمكان نقضي العشر سنوات القادمة
بالإمكان نقضي العشر سنوات القادمة بنصف
ما قضينا العشر سنوات الماضية .
كل تساؤلاتنا حول التقنيات على سبيل المثال
تقنية (AI) هي في سلبياتها، الأثار الجانبية
كثيرة، لا نُخفي ذلك لكن
بالإمكان نستعصر
فائدتها وناخد خلاصة إيجابياتها ونقودها،
نطوعها لنا، مثلما طوعنا الهاتف وطوعنا
التقنيات الأخرى، والتكيف معها لنرتقي بها.
في قصة حدثت في الثورة الصناعية الثالثة،
كان بين صاحب شركة جرافات وبين رئيس بلدية
في أمريكا، كان يمشي في الشارع
صاحب الجرافات مع رئيس البلدية، وهم مارين
على حقل من حقول القمح.
رئيس البلدية ينظر إلى صاحب الجرافات يقول
له بعد ما يتم إنتاج هذه الجرافات التي
تزعم أنك سوف تطلقها في السوق،
نصف أولئك الناس لن يحصلوا على
الوظائف، لأن الحفارين والأشخاص يعملون
فلاحين على المعاول وعلى الحفارات
اليدوية.
قال له بالفعل بعد أن تنتج هذا المنتج
الجرافات نصف هذا الناس وأكثر من نصف لن
يحصلوا وظائف.
فسأله سؤال: هل تريد عدد حفارين أكبر؟
تريد أن توظف حفارين أكثر؟
قال نعم.
قال إذاً استبدل الحفارات اليدوية
والمعاول بالملاعق،
وبالإمكان أن توظف عدد أكبر.
أعتقد العالم والأمة لا يحتاجون
لعدد حفارين أكبر،
نحن بحاجة إلى مبتكرين ومنتجين مطورين
لتحسين تجربتنا في الحياة.
كل هذه التقنيات مهما بلغت ومهما تطورت
ومهما أصبحت ثورية لن تكون إلا محسن
لتجربتنا في الحياة.
المستقبل ليس للأكثر جهداً ولا للألمع
ذكاءً، المستقبل للأسرع تكيفا ً.
شكراً جزيلاً.
(تصفيق)